secure the tournament so rook check but
the king will step
i can can step anywhere right you can
step forwards and backwards
yeah it can step forward most likely you
want to step forward yeah i kind of want
to step forward if you want to be safe
you can step back and okay
rick takes pawn everything's getting
traded off now
i think we're gonna see the past of the
pawn push okay we see a check it's just
gonna give
all the tracks and the problem is if the
black king runs towards that white rook
then the black pawns will drop so
white's just going to give check forever
we're about to find a winner for the
tournament and there we go it's a draw
wesley so wins the chessable masters
it's over the fantastic wesley soul
winning his third tournament in the
meltwater champions chess tour
and his favorite banana sweater he does
it and there we have a smile from the
champion
wesley so wow uh congratulations to him
how impressed are you again ivanka with
wesley so i'm totally